bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bonjour yves bonjour olivier ernest
jean-marie oui bonjour au bioscope
bonjour au iv bonjour la martinique in
voilà donc on vous connaît maintenant
assez bien en martinique vous êtes ce
citoyen ordinaire comme vous aimez à
vous présenter qui défend la démocratie
participative la vrai j'ai envie de dire
entre guillemets parce que vous estimez
que elle commence à être un peu dévoyé
sous certains aspects au cette
démocratie participative on y reviendra
en fait on vous invitez parce que vous
venez de publier donc un nouvel ouvrage
intitulé démocratie de la lumière alors
la lumière ça s'opposent bon je n'irais
pas jusqu'à dire l'obscurantisme où les
ténèbres mais au moins à l'obscurité à
la pénombre alors en un mot est ce que
cela veut dire pour vous en parlant de
démocratie de la lumière que vous voulez
promouvoir que la démocratie est en
danger en france et en martinique en ce
moment où depuis quelques temps oui on a
l'habitude de le tenir pour acquise la
démocratie en martinique en france et
dans le monde
elle et elle est menacée elle est
menacée et c'est clair que en reprenant
les mots de martinique est célèbre on a
l'impression que l'ombre gagne et pas
seulement donc en france avec les taux
des partis populistes notamment du front
national mais aussi donc en europe mais
aussi au brésil mais aussi aux états
unis donc oui la démocratie est menacée
c'est quelque chose que nous devons
protéger nous les citoyens ordinaires
même si nous ne sommes pas élus alors
le livre donc cessé un petit fascicule
démocratie de la lumière donc est
sous-titré demandes et propositions d'un
citoyen ordinaire donc donc vous
formuler des demandes et des suggestions
on va y revenir sur un ou deux exemples
de ces demandes et suggestions mais
alors vous vous adressez dites-vous aux
acteurs clés de notre démocratie alors
évidemment le personnel politique mais
en premier lieu sur tous les citoyens
mais pas seulement exactement la
question que je pose à travers c'était
celle-là et les les tentatives de
réponses que j'arpente la question c'est
que pouvons nous faire nous les citoyens
mais aussi les élus et aussi les
fonctionnaires publics donc les agents
des services publics et puis aussi les
journalistes comment on peut faire pour
peut rallumer notre démocratie qui
s'éteint petit à petit alors vous avez
quelques maîtres mots que vous présentez
comme ça pour finalement incité
également les citoyens on a dit que vous
adressé en premier lieu à eux pour les
inciter à davantage de s'engager
justement dans la pratique ou pour
suggérer aussi aux uns et aux autres de
pratiquer la démocratie participative et
vous utilisez les mots d' enthousiasme
d'engagement d'espoir de confiance
d'optimisme alors certains peut-être
vous dirais aussi qu'il s'agit là de
voeux pieux d'un catalogue de bonnes
intentions
oui tout à fait alors et moi mon combat
si vous voulez c'est de dire à tous les
acteurs clés mais en priorité aux
citoyens qu'ils ont une responsabilité
dans la gestion de la démocratie qui
sont co responsables de l'état de santé
de la démocratie que ce n'est pas que de
la responsabilité des élus aux des
agents des services publics
nous avons le pouvoir de changer les
choses et quand nous nous mobilisons
nous pouvons faire évoluer aussi les
positions des hommes politiques quand on
voit par exemple ce qui se passe en
france avec la sphère du siècle donc la
pétition
sur donc l'environnement comment on fait
quand elle a influencé le discours de
tous les politiques sur la question
écologique par exemple quand on voit par
exemple qu'en martinique une
mobilisation de citoyens qui est
peut-être un peu en fait donc à fond
larion à sainte luce fait évoluer la
position de députés à l'assemblée
nationale par exemple
donc nous nous sommes coresponsables de
notre société et de nos institutions
même si nous ne sommes pas élus votre
propos finalement quel est il si vous
voulez convaincre les uns et les autres
que il faut davantage finalement agir
sur le terrain c'est à dire voilà papa
pas se contenter de paroles où je sais
pas moi qui fais les choses nous faut
nous étaient baissées ben il faut qu'on
qu'on puisse donc s'engager alors ça
vous dit aussi que les élus ont eux ont
la responsabilité de créer les
conditions où justement de cet
engagement là mais on doit pas attendre
les élus nous les citoyens et on voit
bien comment la mobilisation des
citoyens sur le chlordécone même si on
peut on peut penser qu'elle est un peu
timide parce que y'a pas vingt mille
trente mille personnes dans les rues on
voit bien comment cette mobilisation l'a
fait aussi changer la position des élus
sur cette question du du chlordécone
je prends l'exemple donc de deux de ses
rejets de chimie qui dans les années
2012 2013 était favorable à l'approché
de l'épandage aérien aujourd'hui il est
président d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire donc quand les élus quand
les citoyens se mobilisent ils font
changer les élus alors cette publication
olivier renaissent jean-marie démocratie
de la lumière ça se veut quoi une sorte
de guide
un livre qui donne des outils des modes
opératoires pour justement récitation
c'est une incitation à ce que les
acteurs de la démocratie en gage des
relations d'adulte à adulte c'est que
vous le cap à l'est pas grand monde et
dans ceux démocratie de la lumière là je
propose un guide d'entretien
en fait compte entre un candidat et un
citoyen et l'idée c'est que le citoyen
puisse aussi utiliser donc des outils de
confrontation bienveillante avec les
candidats au delà de bon qui ça ok il
fait bon - mais en fait compte qu'ils
projet eau pour communauté nous qui
moignon camp mais la loupe les douves en
quelques mots sur cette mise en garde
aussi que vous faites en quelque sorte
contre ce que vous désignez ce que vous
appelez l'instrumentalisation de la
démocratie participative
vous dites attention faut y regarder à
deux fois parce que certains présentent
ça peut-être comme je sais pas moi un
gimmick un gadget et puis bon ne font
pas vraiment dans la démocratie par ou
exploite un tel que vous vous la
concevez en tout cas pas exactement et
l'idée c'est que aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'il ya une demande de
participation de tous les citoyens et
donc face à ça les politiques sont
tentés donc de mettre en place des
dispositifs qui favorise la
participation mais quelquefois ils le
font de façon maladroite ou de façon
intentionnelle 3 pour calmer une couleur
et c'était le cas par exemple pour avec
le grand débat national
on voit bien que il ya eu une grande
avancée démocratique
avec ce grand débat national a
malheureusement c'est dommage on a
l'impression que ça a été
instrumentalisé par le président pour
calmer le jeu pour gagner du temps
les ponts pour garder le cap et c'est le
cas aussi par exemple en termes de
démocratie participative pour la
consultation sur le drapeau donc en
martinique et surligne on a eu
l'impression qu'on n'aurait pu décider
mais en fait compte bon tout est à
cadenasser verrouillé par une seule
personne alors
on va falloir conclure olivier en est
jean marie donc juste avant de parler
d'un rendez vous que vous donner demain
soir à fort de france
comment s'organiser au mieux parce qu'il
ya un chapitre à une partie du livre qui
est consacré ce que vous avez fait
allusion aux grands débats qui est
consacré donc au mouvement d'aidé gilet
jaune
comment comment finalement au bout du
compte vous le percevez bon un mouvement
d'ailleurs qui dont certains disent
qu'ils s'essoufflent la dernière
manifestation a réuni semble-t-il moins
de dix mille personnes dans toute la
france vont en martinique que ça a
disparu des radars médiatiques on n'en
parle pas déjà depuis oui mais je croise
les casseurs alors ont mesuré la
longueur d'onde de ce mouvement là il
faut remercier les gilets jaunes parce
que sans les gilet jaune par exemple y
aurait pas eu de grand débat national et
le grand des drainages en avait tous les
aspects de nos jours et mes enfants mais
je veux dire qu'il faut quand même et
rendre grâce aussi à ses gilets jaunes
là qui se sont mobilisés parce qu'il n'y
aurait pas eu de grand débat national
qui a montré que la démocratie
participative c'est pas c'est pas le
chaos c'est pas n'importe quoi ça
s'organise
et puis je suis au tout aussi sur la
question donc d'aider de la démocratie
participative et du gilet jaune
je pense aux think on aura du mal à on a
du mal dans l'immédiat à mesurer la
longueur de de ceux de ce mouvement là
alors pour conclure donc olivier est
jean-marie pour pour ainsi dire pour
joindre l'action aux paroles vous donc
proposé un atelier participatif
on y revient donc ce ce jeudi donc
demain au théâtre autonome ma ronde de
la croix mission à à fort de france à
partir de 18h30
donc voilà à partir de cette question
que pouvons nous faire pour sortir notre
démocratie de l'ombre oui voila je n'ai
pas connu sur ce n'est pas vous la
tolérance une conférence débat classique
où il ya conférencier et puis un public
donc j'ai voulu impliquer donc justement
le public dans la recherche de solutions
de la même façon que moi je fais des
propositions
j'invite tous les tous les martiniquais
et tous les citoyens à faire des
propositions et puis pour revenir sur la
question des gilets jaunes aussi y
aurait pas eu de
deux référendums d'initiative partagée
sur la privatisation des aéroports de
paris sans les gilets jaunes
donc voilà donc demain à 18h30 vous
donner rendez vous pour cet atelier
participatif où chacun et chacune auront
la possibilité de demander d'évaluer de
proposer aussi de faire certaines
propositions
bonne journée à tous merci au revoir
virginie le bras